this village used to be home to around
800 people then the russians came
and there was just one
lydia zaika never left as others ran for
safety she stayed
[Music]
when there was shelling she hid in her
basement for a month the 72 year old
slept here too with just her cat for
company
when there was heavy shelling the ground
would shake and i would slightly open
the door just to see if it was my house
or somewhere else when neighbors houses
started to burn i tried to put out the
flames but there was just too much
she wasn't scared she says a voice told
her she would be safe
i saw two soldiers i saw the yellow and
blue stripes i knew they were ukrainians
and i knew then i could come out
the devastation in motion is obvious
homes destroyed ripped apart in the
fighting people are now returning
with one charity on hand giving basics
to people who have lost everything we
are providing medical support we're
providing food support
baby food children food and also various
toys for the kids it seems simple but at
the other hand they're very expensive
for these people for the people in the
village the rebuild may have started but
the danger is still here they used to be
able to use the forest any time they
wanted but this area is now sealed off
because there are mines there and no one
knows where they are
some cried when they saw the shell of
the place they called home
but they are
rebuilding
they have no choice this is all they
have special
below everything we have got was
destroyed nothing left and we have to
start again from scratch it will take
years
lydia zaika is glad people are coming
back she says it's nice to see old faces
nice to no longer have to hide
nice to no longer have a war raging on
her doorstep
alan fisher al jazeera motion ukraine